he's not my favorite rapper but I feel
like Drake is the best rapper I'm not my
favorite I respect that I respect that
opinion yeah Beverly what about you oh I
got a lot of favorite rappers too over
the top of my head
um Nicki Minaj shout out to Nikki uh
younger me shout out to you may
um
my last one
uh I was tired
with a little baby and little Dirk
no baby and little Dirk I like little
baby too I think a little baby I feel
like they sounds compliment each other
you like the joint joint element yeah
there's a little slapped on they're like
they're different but when they come
together it's amazing I agree like
they're both good on their own too who's
better I say a little dirt you think
Dirk is a better rapper than little baby
I like Dirk better okay I feel like Dirk
make better music really that's what my
opinion for a little baby yeah bro like
who's a better at rapping who's better
all right rapping rapping skill Wise
It's a little baby yeah okay I just want
to make sure that's not it's not old
about making a good song
it is it is it is you know what you know
what little baby got a little dirt don't
got what hits
like actually yeah tell me one hit like
a real hit I'm not talking about
screaming I'm not talking about in the
streets in the club on tomorrow you got
in the car
and the radio was on and I'm not talking
about laugh now cry later I was just yo
what
the [__] that is a Drake song I was
about to say I saw good Drake I heard
that shirt because you get to have a
surreal he is
whose song was that tell me the little
Dirk song that has been an actual hit it
doesn't exist
I'm talking about like top 10 on
billboard by himself
but this is not like babies
little baby got 15 of those Yeah Lil
Durk was up and then he went down and
then he came up quick you know what I
love about Derek though is his story
because he's like you know like he's
he's evolved so much in front of our
eyes
he's missing the hit record though he
got a he got he I think it'll separate
him you know I was crazy
it's crazy that I'm right yeah
she's like bro's about to say laugh now
uh
that's it you want to hit this you guys
know you guys gotta rap snow let's put
that up
um
uh talk about just like in your opinion
do you feel like
um
both you guys are 20 both of you fairly
new to taking this [__] serious
we always hear about like negative
aspects of the music industry have you
guys experience anything you don't like
about being in the music industry any
fake [__] you've encountered anything
that's just a lot of fiction oh my God I
feel like
industry is mad for you the industries I
was about to say the industry itself
this week I don't know it's like a game
to it it's a game you gotta play the
game it's like yes it is you ought to
play with the win
or you're just not gonna play by the
rules okay that's why I tell people I'm
like man you gotta kind of just give in
a little and play the game and then
there's people telling like yo we got to
get up we gotta do something we got to
work and then you never hear from them
yeah uh what is the best chopped cheese
in Brooklyn
I don't know Jesus I'm really more of a
big [__] juice type of nugget okay I
had chopped cheese a few times in your
life no no I'm alive I'm still like like
three two years ago back to back I just
know the hoods not to get it from
Bushwick oh yeah don't go to Bushwick
for your chopped cheese
is the same thing though
yeah Williamsburg is like I don't even
know what it is I don't think
Williamsburg knows how to make anything
no they have they probably got a bunch
of organic [__] and and again let's
get back to the independent coffee shops
I had coffee one time
not against her I had coffee one time
like one time
but kofi's not good like it doesn't
taste
you've never had coffee in your life
gangster
it doesn't taste
the time I had coffee had to force
myself to drink it you had coffee once
in your life yeah to stay up
and it's it kept me up guys
yeah I never been to Starbucks
oh yeah I've been to Starbucks and I
picked out a big old cheese
cream cheese
that shit's crazy to me he never had I
use other things to like boost my energy
it's not cocaine right good that's not
good I look okay we don't do no cool kid
that's good yo what do you use to boost
your energy you take like a five hour
shot
yeah I guess we could call it that what
about you
no coffee that's [__] wild to me I
drink coffee every [__] day of my
it's like I would be asleep stay up or
just I don't know yeah maybe I just
gotta get up and have a black coffee
black I like it black oh my goodness
there's a difference between black and
white gold so white coffee
okay so let me tell you right so all
copy is originally black
and then it becomes Williamsburg
gentrified I'll see what you're saying
okay gentrify the black coffee with some
caramel maybe some heavy cream maybe
some half and half maybe some almond
milk y'all like coffee
I said dirt right
it's nasty it just keeps it just gets
the job done have you guys ever had a
caramel macchiato I don't even like
caramel frappes from McDonald's
yeah you got it's a vanilla latte
there's egg yes
vanilla latte oh man y'all got a little
[__] McDonald's they got great coffee
I mean I'm gonna grate everything at
McDonald's for being honest McDonald's
is fire I just like pointed out you guys
like McDonald's
don't get up here because every time
I'll be like let's go to McDonald's
is after hours
I agree I agree but we just can't
everyone acts like McDonald's isn't good
it's mad it's not good for you but it's
[__] amazing I should have tasted you
no good I don't know what it is you get
a [__] cheeseburger and you stuff it
with fries with their with their you
wash it down with that
signature only McDonald's Coke because
it doesn't taste do you believe me
telling us like we can't relate I ain't
gonna lie and guess what the McDonald's
Sprite that's the wacky Sprite it's the
only Sprite that tastes like that that's
good it tastes like it's McDonald's
spray TV status I don't know TV static
is crazy like it charges my arteries
right yeah it's like what about the
orange High Sea from McDonald's Orange
icy this shit's fire I like the food
like after 12 everything closed yeah we
eat a lot though so that's like the
fourth today